they went to Florence Florence was it's
a great City
yeah so then the wedding happens and
it's the night before and mind you
Alina had to quarterback this whole
thing because there's just certain [ __ ]
that like wasn't being communicated and
we tried to do this whole wedding on
such a small timeline we had 12 weeks
do it all okay flowers you know you're
going through it so we get there and
it's like two in the morning we got
we're kind of like winding out of the
day from Florence and her sister's like
yo so I was kind of talking to the
wedding planner and the
uh have you guys thought about this have
you thought about that and we're like oh
yeah the ceremony okay we don't really
iron out like
like we're just kind of like yeah you
know I'm gonna walk out there and then
just she'll walk out there and it should
be fine right I guess we need some
chairs too yeah the people dude where
are we gonna do it so then we kind of
like figure out like who's telling the
violinist to play what yeah you know
just like all those little minutia
things and then her sister's like you're
like a best man or anything I'm like no
actually is anyone getting ready with
you I'm like I'm thinking about it and
she's like does anyone
like I didn't we didn't even like talk
about like you know people were supposed
to write letters to you and [ __ ] I was
like I thought I was just gonna put on
my suit and just play a tower defense
game on my phone and then just walk out
there like when it's time for my set and
she's like
and she's like no dude that's not how
you do this Taylor pulls up and he's
like help me get ready and
sibo is there too and so then because I
slept at the wedding party I'm like
terrified that I'm gonna start to get
the itis during the ceremony it's a
couple hours before I'm getting ready
and I just feel it it's starting to like
hit I'm like hey yo
I gotta take a nap and they're like okay
so take a nap I didn't [ __ ] it up then I
get the letters from people it looks
like my dad brother-in-law whatever I
didn't have to read them but I decided
to speedrun them minutes before I'm
supposed to go out what are the letters
is this like a wedding thing yeah
exactly I don't know exactly dude okay
is this I've never heard of this well
it's just sort of like you may get you
know some words of wisdom from your
family about like you're about to enter
marriage this is like advice and you
read them right before you go out you
don't have to okay I did okay just
Speed Run not tool assisted we just
matched through five deep very deep
meaningful pieces of media right right
before I go out there so you're already
building the base that's what I thought
I literally said that to myself I'm like
yes you know kind of put me in the
mindset I get through letter one and I'm
like
[ __ ] okay I'll try not to cry I get to
the second one I'm like whoa
what are these things in my chest
so I get through all five thankfully my
brother-in-law writes me on this really
long but it's like really funny
cope we're good we're good then I go out
there it's like it's time I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm even getting nervous now
talking about it and I'm about to walk
down and they like start playing the
song and I'm just like uh and it just it
starts coming and then her song and it
just comes more and I'm just looking
down the whole time
because I can't I can't even look at
anyone in the crowd it's [ __ ] me up
so bad
and then she walks out and I'm like go
back inside
this is way too vulnerable you're too
beautiful yeah literally I'm like I
can't handle it
way more than I had planned
dude your dress is banging that's what I
said yo you look hot as [ __ ] by the way
that's what you say when she first gets
up yeah hi you look [ __ ] hot yeah
I want to [ __ ] lay you down right now
yeah yeah
cannot wait to consummate this merge
also your tits looking soon
I think I can see your nipple and it's
like
I can't stay up here much longer get me
out of here
[Laughter]
can I read my I was fully torqued or
that'd be weird
no instead I just like wept like a child
she walks up and then she like starts
looking up she's like okay look at you
can't look at you so then whatever kind
of settles in I can't we kind of [ __ ]
around during the vows a little bit it
was like the night before and like a
couple nights before she's like are we
doing vows I'm like those are corny so
yeah
then everyone's you know you're not
doing vows like we didn't think through
this part
it was it was funny how many steps we
just kind of glossed over you know even
with the cake but oh yeah I guess
someone kind of yeah you guys like cake
yeah yeah what kind of cake
so you know ceremony beautiful all that
starts huh chocolate yeah yeah
it starts to rain just a little bit okay
just for the pictures but here the
coolest part or I mean um a cool part
not the coolest part
this I did not just say that the coolest
part was the part with the car
a very cool part
I rented a like a 1966 uh Porsche 356
and then she got it and I got in and we
drove off oh sick it was pretty cool
um it was just pretty cool yeah yeah
it was pretty cool list I mean yeah I
keep using that it was like the best it
was a pretty cool best part of the day
so
yeah yeah then I kind of fell asleep the
jet lag hit me after I after I drove the
car it's pretty spent yeah
yeah
I wish I married the car actually what
the best day of your life let's just say
no so uh yeah yeah no I mean you know
people say that like oh my wedding was
the greatest day of my life and
obviously I understood that after the
fact we had the dinner
we
uh we got like the smallest Dance Floor
ever because we're like yeah we'll just
[ __ ] around got a DJ booth we just put
together a Spotify playlist and then we
set up the Crossfade feature and we
thought that should be fine yeah kind of
didn't factor that some songs have
really long outros okay so we finished
our first dance and the next song is
Take so there's a good 20 seconds for
everyone's
thank you
is it gonna and then the internet dies
this is like the only real hiccup but it
was funny I'll just play it on my phone
yeah yeah
so I go over a week yeah
so we go figure it out like takes two
seconds and then the music starts
everyone starts dancing and then you
know me being me I don't like the way
the playlist is going I saw half on the
ones and twos okay and then I'm just
going back and forth with the microphone
okay you know setting up the next song
after dancing with Elena and so you
emceed your own wedding yeah
yeah I just couldn't stay away I saw a
microphone and I'm like I need that I
gotta talk some [ __ ] right now
there's someone with like a red Ford
Fiero parked out front all night it's
really weird yeah then towards the end
of the night so DJs will always play you
know like songs that maybe get the
ladies turned up
and I decided to play back that ass I'm
just thinking
it's a wedding right we're all gonna
know this is tongue-in-cheek
I don't know what no it went over fine I
don't know what it is about that song I
put it on and just an instinct tapped in
and then everyone just all ever
everyone's just starting to bend a lot
lower
you know everyone's starting to shake
his aunt was working it dude people
start shaking some ass
I don't like family
I mean
they're thinking about it it's
definitely hitting you know like
definitely some of the family members
kind of like I might no you know what
Memaw was throwing ass
I don't know who my second aunt was but
Brad am I blood related to her she's
blowing that [ __ ] bro
I'm like God damn related
laughs that's my aunt though
she slides the ring off
that's my aunt though
second aunt though oh or she's like so
many sisters
by merger Blood by marriage
so yeah
um a little photo booth the whole thing
we had we had cake we had a little
gelato cart nice almost no one knew the
gelato car was there right until he was
leaving
he like comes up and he's like it's uh
11 it's time for me to leave everyone's
like who are you
it's a gelato whole wedding party just
gets in line and he's like he was great
oh we had him a couple nights so
whatever wedding is
you know
greatest [ __ ] ever someone could have
shot me right there it would have been
fine
um
then we had the next American Wedding
yeah yeah yeah